.
In Schweden
wollen die Gäste der Familie Rotzler
so richtig ins Schwitzen kommen.
Auswanderer Jonas feuert
daher zum ersten Mal die Sauna ein.
Das ist ein Feuer
mit ganz wenig Sauerstoff.
Wenn man die Tür öffnet
und Sauerstoff hereinkommt,
kann es
eine Rauchgasexplosion geben.
Das ist saugefährlich.
Ha! Die Tür schliessen und beten.
Mit grossen Träumen brechen
Anita Thomi und Alain Aegerter
nach Griechenland auf.
Ihr Plan:
Ferien für Reptilienfreunde anbieten.
Juhu.
Doch kaum angekommen,
der grosse Schock:
Ihr Heim brennt
bis auf die Grundmauern ab.
Sie verlieren ihr ganzes Hab und Gut.
Scheisse.
Aus dem Mansion am Meer in Kanada
wollen Barbara Hasenböhler
und ihr Partner Thomas Range
ein luxuriöses Gästehaus
mit sieben Zimmern machen.
Nun kriegt das Haus Augen.
Alles, was sie besitzen,
stecken sie in das Projekt.
Während Barbara den Bau managt,
jobbt Thomas in einem Café.
In Schweden übernimmt Familie Rotzler
eine Ferienanlage mit 20 Gebäuden
und mit ihr viel Arbeit,
Mobiliar und noch mehr Kram.
2014 abgelaufen.
Kaum angekommen,
müssen sie schon alles
für den Gästebetrieb vorbereiten.
Bei der Besichtigung der Zimmer
machen sie einen überraschenden Fund.
Was ist das in der Ecke?
- Ah, deshalb stank es so.
Das ist irgendeine seltsame Ratte.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Noch war der Kammerjäger nicht da,
aber Familie Rotzler hat
momentan sowieso andere Probleme.
In weniger als 8 Std.
kommen die ersten Gäste.
Jonas hat Decke, Wände und Fenster
in der Gaststube frisch gestrichen.
Mehrere Tage arbeitete er daran,
oft bis spät in die Nacht.
Auch Nachbar Ulf packt mit an.
Er kümmert sich um die neuen Lampen.
(Ulf) Does it look good, Jonas?
- Hä?
(Ulf)
(Jonas)
Wenn man versucht, es perfekt
zu machen, wird man nie fertig.
Irgendwann wollen wir ja eröffnen.
Alle helfen mit: Sabrina bereitet mit
den drei Kindern die Gästezimmer vor.
Ta-da. Diese legen wir
auf die Betten.
Legen wir
die ganze Schachtel aufs Bett?
* Lachen *
Trotz Zeitdruck:
Familie Rotzler ist die Ruhe selbst.
* Verträumte Klänge *
Die Ferienanlage der Auswanderer
liegt an einer Nationalstrasse.
Sie verbindet die Orte
Bollnäs im Norden und Falun im Süden.
Verpflegungsmöglichkeiten gibt es -
ausser bald bei Familie Rotzler -
kaum.
Hej.
(Mann)
Yes, please.
Ja, ich mache noch mehr Sandwiches.
(Sabrina)
Zwei Reisende
wollen hier Pause machen.
Das machen wir, obwohl wir offiziell
noch nicht geöffnet haben.
Ich finde, das gehört sich einfach.
Ich belege es noch mit Schinken.
Geht's?
- Ja.
Aber halt es gut fest.
* Lachen *
Die sechsjährige Fiona
übt schon mal servieren.
Super gemacht.
- Vielen Dank.
Gut gemacht.
(Sabrina, Schwedisch)
(Ulf) Eva?
- Ja?
(Sabrina) Tack, Eva.
- (Ulf) Lamp.
(Sabrina und Ulf) Oh!
(Ulf) Light is in God's house.
* Er lacht. *
Bis zu 60 Personen
kann Familie Rotzler beherbergen.
* Klavierklänge *
Hier kommt die Bettwäsche.
Die ersten Gäste bringen sie
im grossen Gästehaus unter.
Eigentlich hatten sie für die Gruppe
das kleinere Gästehaus vorgesehen,
doch das muss noch
vom Kammerjäger inspiziert werden.
Die Schädlingsbekämpfungsfirma
kommt nächste Woche.
* Kreischen *
Ich komme, Kian.
Dann wissen wir, wo das Problem
liegt, und können es beheben.
Ich bringe keine Gäste in dem Haus
unter, wenn ich nicht weiss,
ob wieder jemand
durch die Kanalisation reinkommt
und Hallo sagt.
Ich hasse Bügeln eigentlich.
Nicht aufs Bett!
- Es ist so warm.
Ja, aber ich habe es schon
für die Gäste vorbereitet.
Du kannst nicht aufs Bett, wenn ich
es für die Gäste vorbereitet habe.
Die Tavernen an der Hafenpromenade
in Koroni sind alle geschlossen.
Es ist Winter
auf dem griechischen Peloponnes.
Wir brechen noch
den letzten Teil unseres Hauses ab.
Das ist
unser ehemaliges Schlafzimmer.
Huhu!
Lucky, ein Nachbar,
hilft Alain und Anita.
Gut sechs Monate sind seit
dem verheerenden Feuer vergangen.
Anita trennt den Brandschutt.
Mit den Steinen
terrassieren sie das Gelände.
Metall, Plastik und Glas
werden entsorgt.
Das ist der Rest
einer Vase von Alains Grossmutter.
Man findet jeweils einzelne Stücke,
die man identifizieren kann.
Das ist schon traurig.
* Ruhige Musik *
Was im Sommer gänzlich fehlt,
gibt es im Winter fast zu oft:
kalten Wind und heftigen Regen.
Hui!
Hört es wohl gleich wieder auf?
Oder soll ich das Ganze abdecken?
Und in 2 Min. ...
Bis wir es abgedeckt haben,
hört es auf.
Die Emmentaler
reissen nicht alles ab.
Auf dem bestehenden Fundament
wollen sie das Haus wieder aufbauen.
Noch immer fällt es Alain schwer,
den Verlust des alten Heims
zu akzeptieren.
Wenn wir wieder hier wohnen wollen,
müssen wir etwas tun.
Und ich bin eher derjenige, der ...
Es nervt mich schon.
Das ist unbestritten.
Aber ich will hier
nicht mein halbes Leben
mit Jammern und Leiden verbringen.
Alles, was noch brauchbar ist,
wollen sie weiterverwenden.
Aus dem Kaminstein
will Alain einen Schacht
für Kabel und Wasserleitungen bauen.
Jetzt ist er zerbrochen.
- Zerbrochen?
Mhm.
- Denkst du, das liegt an der Hitze?
Vielleicht, ich weiss es nicht.
Schubkarre um Schubkarre.
Es ist ein mühsamer Weg, bis Alain
und Anita hier wieder wohnen können.
Langsamer als gedacht
geht es auch bei Barbara Hasenböhler
und ihrem Partner Thomas Range
in Kanada.
9 Uhr.
- Ja.
In einer Stunde ist Kaffeepause.
Ich komme.
* Sie stöhnt. *
Machst du das jetzt?
- Mhm.
Nein, alles okay, Schatz.
Ça marche, ça marche, ça marche.
Barbara hatte einen Unfall.
Vor drei Wochen hat sie sich auf
der Baustelle den Knöchel gebrochen.
Wegen der Bauarbeiten
entfernten wir den Rasen.
An einigen Stellen
ist daher nur blanker Erdboden.
Der Boden auf dieser Insel
ist total lehmig.
Der Boden war nass
und spiegelglatt - wie Eis.
Ich betrat diese Stelle
und fiel hin.
Ich zog mir einen Splitterbruch zu.
Ich musste operiert werden und
nun sind Platten und Schrauben drin.
Das ist wie beim Autofahren:
Man beherrscht das Rückwärtsfahren
nicht von Anfang an.
Aber so langsam klappt's.
Barbaras Unfall kommt zu
einem denkbar schlechten Zeitpunkt.
Denn der Umbau ihrer Villa
zu einem Gästehaus
muss so schnell wie möglich
fertig werden.
* Dynamische Musik *
Auf Prince Edward Island
beginnt die Lobster Season,
und mit dem Hummer
kommen bald auch die Touristen.
* Bellen *
Thomas muss nun anstelle von Barbara
den Laden schmeissen.
Mit den Hunden rauszugehen
ist dabei noch das Geringste.
Hasenherz, assistierst du mir?
Hier, nimm das bitte mit.
Ich gebe es dir gleich.
- Genau.
Warte, einen Moment.
Das ist nicht so ... In dieser Hütte
gibt es überall Hindernisse.
Du musst die Bremse
da unten noch lösen.
Ja, Schatzi. Ich habe Angst,
dass es dann zu schnell geht.
So.
Bis vor einem Tag
durfte Barbara nur liegen.
Den Umbau beaufsichtigen - unmöglich.
Alles okay? Brauchst du noch was?
- Ne, sonst habe ich alles.
Der Laptop ist hier.
Das Spannende für mich ist,
dass ich all die Dinge,
die ich wirklich nicht gern mache,
nun hier umsetzen muss -
in folgender Reihenfolge:
Erstens,
alles, was mit dem Bau zu tun hat,
zweitens,
alles, was mit der Küche zu tun hat,
und drittens: Einkaufen.
In den letzten Tagen und Wochen
lag das alles bei mir.
Ich bin nicht happy
mit der Situation,
aber es hilft ja nichts.
Wir machen weiter und
machen das Beste daraus.- Genau.
Und wir haben Buchungen.
Wir müssen eröffnen.
Brav, so ist es gut.
Ob es Thomas gefällt oder nicht:
Er ist nun Bauleiter,
Koch und Krankenpfleger.
Fast fertig,
dank der tatkräftigen Unterstützung
von Ulf und seiner Frau Eva.
(Schwedisch)
Bei Familie Rotzler in Schweden
können jede Sekunde
die Gäste eintreffen.
Nur noch wenig erinnert an das Chaos,
das noch vor ein paar Stunden
in der Gaststube herrschte.
Jetzt muss nur noch
der selbst gebackene Kuchen
in die Kühlvitrine,
dann ist eigentlich alles parat.
* Kurzes Surren *
Das war ein Kurzschluss.
Alles andere
funktioniert allerdings noch.
Ähm ...
Hm!
Die Kühlvitrine ist ausgestiegen -
ausgerechnet jetzt.
Ich schaue,
ob eine Sicherung durchgebrannt ist,
aber es sieht nicht danach aus.
(Ulf) Jonas!
(Ulf)
Um den Defekt
muss er sich später kümmern.
Hello.
(Englisch)
Die vier kommen aus Stockholm
und wollen
auf der Ferienanlage Skalsjögarden
das Wochenende verbringen.
Die vier Jungs
haben Halbpension gebucht.
(Sabrina) Gefällt ihnen das Zimmer?
Bis jetzt
hörte ich nichts Negatives.
Nun müssen wir kurz schauen ...
Ich wusste, dass sie dann kommen,
wenn ich mit den Kindern umziehe.
Der ist total schön.
Jonas muss das Abendessen auf den
Tisch zaubern - ein Dreigangmenü.
Wow!- Der Bauch darf
einfach nicht zu dick sein.
Kian trug ihn.
Der ehemalige Qualitätsmanager
hat eine Stunde Zeit zum Kochen.
* Kinderweinen *
Oh, der Nächste heult.
Zum Hauptgang
gibt es Lachs mit Gemüse und Reis.
Zur Vorspeise einen Salat.
Am besten kocht man das,
was man auch für sich selbst kocht.
Das klappt meist am besten.
Wie spät ist es?
- 18.17 Uhr.
Die Jungs geniessen schon
den selbst mitgebrachten Apero.
Noch fehlt Familie Rotzler
die Alkohollizenz.
Ich schaue nach, wie lange
der Lachs gekocht werden muss.
Alle Teller rausnehmen.
Geht das?
- Ja.
Du kannst sie zum Tisch bringen.
Oh, die Messer sind stumpf.
Hm, das hat keinen Sinn.
Ulf und Eva
sind zum Abendessen eingeladen.
Ein Dankeschön für ihre Hilfe.
- So, jetzt.
So ...
* Scheppern *
Äh ... Was machst du?
Wie spät ist es?
- 18.52 Uhr.
Komm, hilf mir.
Wir machen den Fisch fertig.
Ich würde sagen, sie sind gar.
Sollen wir das Salz und den Pfeffer
auf den Tisch stellen?
Salz und Pfeffer.
Gerade halten.
Geradeso geschafft.
Die ruhige Art der Familie Rotzler
zahlt sich einmal mehr aus.
(Englisch)
(Schwedisch)
In Griechenland sind selbst
einfache Dinge für Anita und Alain
nicht mehr selbstverständlich.
Fliessendes Wasser
gibt es nur hinten im Garten.
In der Garage -
unter dem ehemaligen Haus -
haben sie einen Teil der Schildkröten
und die 24 Giftschlangen
untergebracht.
Monatelang warteten sie auf
die Einfuhrbewilligung für die Tiere.
Schliesslich -
neun Wochen nach der Auswanderung -
konnte Alain sie mit einem
Lieferwagen im Emmental abholen.
Wir hatten ja
einen riesigen Stapel Papiere.
Dann wurde ich damit
beim Zoll vorstellig und ...
... irgendwie fühlte sich dort
gar niemand dafür zuständig.
In Chiasso hiess es,
in Bari werde gestempelt,
in Bari hiess es,
in Patras werde gestempelt
und in Patras hiess es:
"Das ist okay."
Willst du vorangehen?
- Nein.
Vorsichtig.
- Ja, ja.
Jeden Zentimeter der Garage
nutzen sie für ihre Tiere.
Die Riesenschildkröten verbringen die
kalten Nächte unter der Wärmelampe.
Danke.
* Sie ächzt. *
Okay?
Ja, alles okay.
Die Parameter stimmen für sie.
Sie haben nur etwas zu wenig Platz.
Aber es gibt keine andere Lösung.
Das ist das einzige Haus,
das wir noch haben.
Alain und Anita müssen improvisieren.
Sobald die griechische Wintersonne
stark genug ist,
bringen sie Olga,
Mimu und Zbinden ins Freigehege.
Ui!- Hast du dir
den Finger eingeklemmt?
Ja, das passiert mir dauernd.
Das kennen wir doch, nicht wahr?
Den Hals massieren.
- Wieder mal etwas Bekanntes.
Es ist schön,
dass sie jetzt hier sind.
Da wir wieder
bei null beginnen müssen,
ist es für sie
natürlich nicht so toll.
Das ist nicht die Tierhaltung,
die ich mir wünsche.
Aber wir müssen
zurzeit auf engem Raum leben
und den Tieren
geht es leider ebenso.
Aber sobald die regnerische
und kalte Zeit vorbei ist -
das wird in zwei bis drei Wochen
der Fall sein -,
können sie wieder
permanent draussen leben.
Zbindi, bist du zufrieden?
Die Tiere sollen
so schnell wie möglich
wieder
ein richtiges Zuhause bekommen.
Vertauschte Rollen
im Mansion am Meer in Kanada.
Dreimal am Tag muss nun Thomas
die Handwerker bewirten.
Vor dem Unfall machte das Barbara.
Barbara muss sich noch immer schonen.
Ihr unerschöpflicher Elan
wurde ausgebremst.
Was bleibt:
telefonieren auf dem Sofa,
und das noch mehrere Wochen lang.
Okay, bye.
Für mich ist das extrem schwierig.
Für mich ist es fast wie Folter,
nicht in die Zimmer gehen zu können,
um zu sehen, was die Jungs machen.
Ich kann nichts kontrollieren.
Es ist eine Art Kontrollverlust.
Seit dem Kauf der Liegenschaft
im Jahr 2019
war es v.a. Barbara, die das Projekt
mit dem Gästehaus vorantrieb.
Thomas gab ihr Rückhalt,
aber blieb im Hintergrund.
Als Gastroprofi weiss er genau,
wie man Gäste glücklich macht.
Er arbeitet schon seit
mehr als 25 Jahren in diesem Metier.
Aber einen Umbau zu koordinieren,
ist für ihn totales Neuland.
Do you want to put that
under the board over there?
Just right over here, Thomas.
- Outside or here?
Durchschnittlich acht Handwerker
arbeiten gleichzeitig
auf der Baustelle.
Das Kernteam als solches
macht einen super Job.
Hier und da gibt
es ein paar kleine Probleme,
die wieder behoben werden müssen.
In diesem Raum, Zimmer 5,
haben die Elektriker,
die diese heat pumps
eingebaut haben,
z.B. in die bereits fertige
Konstruktion reingeschnitten
und Dinge rausgebrochen.
Nun müssen wir
den ganzen Bereich hier reparieren.
Das ist nicht nur hier so,
sondern insgesamt in fünf Zimmern.
D.h., wir haben bestimmt
eineinhalb Wochen verloren.
Es ist wie so oft auf Baustellen:
Alles dauert länger.
(Thomas)
Nicht ohne Grund
hat Barbara vier Wochen als Puffer
für die Bauarbeiten eingeplant.
Relativ viel Material
wurde erst jetzt geliefert.
Einige Dinge hatten wir
bereits letztes Jahr bestellt
und aufgrund diverser Umstände
verschoben sich die Lieferfristen.
Nun konnten sie viel aufholen.
Es ist schön, zu sehen,
dass wir langsam
wieder im grünen Bereich sind.
Okay.
I like it - really.
Die Jungs sind ziemlich stolz.
Es sieht gut aus.
Zeig mal.
- Hier. Es ist ein bisschen viel ...
Mhm.
Jetzt hängen sie sie ein.
Das dauert keine Minute.
Das ist das Badezimmer.
Sie müssen keine Ecke abschneiden,
nicht wahr?
Nein, sie müssen nichts abschneiden.
Es wird noch eine Zierleiste
montiert. Dann ist es bündig.
Cool. Das ist einfach
ein schöner Raum.- Ja.
Nur noch sechs Wochen.
Dann wollen Thomas und Barbara an
diesem Tisch zahlende Gäste bewirten.
Welcome, this is our
toast Hawaii show, without Hawaii.
Buon appetito.
In Schweden heizt Jonas
seit Stunden die Bastu,
die traditionelle Holzsauna ein.
Ihre Stockholmer Gäste
wollen ins Schwitzen kommen.
Wenn ich zum letzten Mal einheize,
muss ich
noch etwas mehr Holz reinlegen,
aber jetzt ist es schon okay.
Das Anfeuern
ist eine Wissenschaft für sich.
Jonas hat sich bei Vorbesitzer Ake
informiert, wie er vorgehen muss.
Nun hoffe ich, dass alles gut geht.
Ansonsten
haben wir ein Haus weniger.
Auch ein heisses Bad im Hotpot
wollen die Gäste nehmen.
Nur der ist
noch lange nicht betriebsbereit.
Der Deckel des Ofens
war wohl längere Zeit offen.
Daher regnete es rein
und er füllte sich mit Wasser.
Jetzt muss ich
alles wieder rauskriegen.
Ein weiteres Problem:
Auch der Kessel rinnt.
Man merkt, dass das Ganze
total vernachlässigt wurde.
Das ist jetzt halt so.
Da müssen wir durch.
Wir packen jeden Tag etwas Neues an
und kommen jeden Tag
einen Schritt weiter.
Irgendwann ist alles wieder auf
dem Stand, auf dem es sein sollte.
Das Wasser ist fast draussen,
jetzt kann er einen Versuch wagen.
Viel Zeit hat Jonas nicht mehr.
Die vier Jungs können jederzeit
von ihrem Ausflug zurückkommen.
Jetzt ist der Kamin kalt.
Dann zieht es
in die falsche Richtung.
Jonas will es perfekt haben.
Denn zufriedene Gäste
geben gute Bewertungen ab.
Das ist
für den Aufbau des Geschäfts wichtig.
Ha!
So muss es sein.
Noch wichtiger aber:
Jonas scheint sich in seiner neuen
Rolle als Gastgeber wohlzufühlen.
Wenn die Gäste happy sind,
es cool finden und sich bedanken,
erfährt man
bei der Arbeit Wertschätzung
und empfindet Zufriedenheit.
Das ist nicht der Fall,
wenn man in einem Büro arbeitet.
Dort bedankt sich keiner.
Wenn man seine Gäste
wirklich zufriedenstellt,
erfährt man das jeden Tag.
Das macht glücklich.
So, mal sehen,
welches Klima hier herrscht.
(Jonas)
Während sich die Gäste entspannen,
geht es für Jonas und Sabrina
noch lange weiter.
Ulf sagte, dass er dir heute Abend
in der Küche helfen würde,
damit ich mit den Kindern
früher rübergehen kann.
Gut.
Hallo, Bleischi.
* Miauen *
Komm, wir holen Kräuter.
So.
Der Garten ist nur einer der Vorteile
von Anitas und Alains neuer Bleibe
in Griechenland.
Die Dreizimmerwohnung
ist auch gross genug,
damit der Rest der Schildkröten
hier überwintern kann.
Hier ist etwas Frisches. Danke.
Schon kurz nach der Feuerkatastrophe
durften die beiden hier einziehen.
Die Wohnung gehört Hans.
Seine Tochter
hatte den Schweizern das Haus,
das abgebrannt ist, verkauft.
Hans bot uns an,
dass wir so lange wie nötig
kostenlos in
seiner Ferienwohnung wohnen dürfen.
Wir mussten fast darum betteln, die
Energiekosten übernehmen zu dürfen.
Das ist total süss.
* Ruhige Musik *
Tag für Tag pendeln sie nun mit
Znünibroten zur Ruine ihres Hauses.
* Ruhige Musik *
Neben der Ruine
lassen sie ein Sanitärhaus bauen,
ein Haus mit Bad und Küche.
Ihr Ziel: So schnell wie möglich
wieder hier oben wohnen.
Jassas. Everything okay?
(Mann) Yeah.
- Good.
Hier ist Mimu.
So ...
Das Wetter ist gut genug,
die Riesenschildkröten
dürfen wieder einmal sonnenbaden.
Anita und Alain ziehen
im neuen Sanitärhaus Kabel ein.
Der gelernte Elektriker
und die ehemalige Disponentin
haben schon ihr Haus im Emmental
gemeinsam renoviert.
Das sind wir uns vom Umbau
des Bauernhauses gewohnt.
Wir zogen ...
... etwa 2 km Kabel ein.
Aber das ist schon länger her.
Anita und Alain
sind seit rund 20 Jahren ein Paar.
In dieser langen Zeit
haben sie schon so manche Hindernisse
gemeinsam überwunden.
Gut. Noch ein bisschen?
Wie viel hast du?
Das ist viel zu wenig.
Der griechische Alltag hält immer
wieder Überraschungen für sie bereit.
Mich macht es am meisten nervös,
wenn ich hierherkomme
und keine Handwerker antreffe.
Man hat einen Termin vereinbart
und die Handwerker sollten kommen,
aber es kommt keiner.
Am nächsten und am übernächsten Tag
ist es wieder dasselbe.
Warte.
Nicht nur die andere Mentalität
ist eine Herausforderung,
auch die Finanzierung.
Wieder zurück?
- Ja, ja.
Ihr Geld wollten sie
in Ferienhäuschen investieren.
Jetzt müssen sie damit den
Wiederaufbau ihres Hauses bezahlen.
Wenn alles so läuft,
wie wir es uns vorgestellt haben
und sich die griechische Regierung
wirklich ...
... an der Finanzierung beteiligt,
sieht es ziemlich gut aus. Warte.
Wenn das nicht der Fall ist,
könnte es wirklich schwierig werden.
Dann müssen wir
vielleicht umdenken ...
... und unsere Zukunftspläne ändern.
Ich glaube, du musst kurz ...
Nein, das ist okay.
- Siehst du das?
Es kann sich keine Schlaufe bilden.
Das ist unmöglich.
Den Antrag für die Wiederaufbauhilfe
haben sie
beim griechischen Staat gestellt.
Ob sie aber tatsächlich
Geld bekommen, ist offen.
Alles im Griff zu haben,
ist in Kanada nun Thomas' Aufgabe.
Bei Joe ein Ding der Unmöglichkeit.
Er ist
ein ganz spezieller Typ Mensch.
Wir sind noch dabei,
ihn kennenzulernen.
Die Kommunikation
müssen wir noch üben.
Man erreicht ihn nie
und dann taucht er plötzlich auf.
Das ist immer
eine etwas verwirrende Situation.
Gärtner Joe ist ein Unikum.
Er kommt und geht, wie es ihm passt.
Heute will er
den Rasentennisplatz vorbereiten.
(Thomas)
(Joe)
Gärtner Joe kümmerte sich
schon bei den Vorbesitzern
um die Grünanlage
und den Tennisplatz.
(Thomas)
(Joe)
Auf Joe
sind die Auswanderer angewiesen.
Er ist der Einzige,
der die Bewässerungsanlage kennt.
Ich spurte jetzt schnell hinterher.
Wir müssen checken, ob das Wasser
am richtigen Ort rauskommt,
bevor etwas kaputtgeht.
Aha.
Der Hahn ist offen,
doch wo bleibt das Wasser?
Oh!
Das ist jetzt gut.
Thomas scheint sich so langsam
in seine neue Rolle einzufinden -
allem Stress zum Trotz.
* Ruhige Musik *
Zum Wohl.
* Bellen *
Schau, Enten.
Einmal die Woche
gehen Anita und Alain
zum Abendessen eine Etage höher.
* Türklingel *
Jeden Dienstag kocht Hans für sie.
Es ist offen.
- Danke.
Hi.
- Guten Abend.
Jetzt gehe ich wieder in die Küche.
Hans ist Holländer und
selbst vor 20 Jahren ausgewandert.
Er war es,
der Anita und ihre Schwiegereltern
durch das Feuer gelotst hatte.
* Alarmton *
Die Küche ruft.
Das gemeinsame Erlebnis verbindet.
Hans überlegte nicht lange
und gewährte den Schweizern in
seiner Einliegerwohnung Unterschlupf.
Sie haben nichts mehr
und die Wohnung stand leer.
Daher dachte ich: "Warum nicht?"
Dass noch 60-70 Tiere hinzukommen,
wusste ich allerdings nicht.
Aber das war
auch kein Problem für mich.
Ich freue mich immer noch,
dass sie hier sind.
Hans ist zu einem guten Freund
geworden, dessen Rat sie schätzen.
Bald schon wollen die Emmentaler
ihre erste Erlebniswoche
für Reptilienfreunde anbieten.
Anita hat ein Konzept gemacht
und einen Flyer kreiert.
Aus diesen drei Wochen ...
... kann man auswählen.
Das sieht nicht schlecht aus.
Ich habe auch geschrieben,
dass sich die Unterkunft wegen des
Brandes noch nicht bei uns befindet.
Sie können in einem Hotel
in Koroni übernachten.
Am Meer.
- Ja.
"Wanderung in der Umgebung".
Die Umgebung kennst du ja.
Ja, ich kenne mich aus.
Das sieht nicht schlecht aus.
Die Erlebniswoche
ist ein erster Versuch,
ihren Auswanderungstraum
wieder aufleben zu lassen.
Zum Wohl.
- Zum Wohl.
In Holland sagt man: "Kein besseres
Leben als ein gutes Leben."
Das wünschen wir uns jetzt.
- Ja.
7 Uhr in der Früh in Schweden.
Abreisetag
auf der Ferienanlage Skalsjögarden.
Wir haben nur diese Brötchen,
nicht wahr?
Ansonsten
haben wir nur Zopf und Toast.
Mhm.
Die Nacht war kurz, wie schon
so oft in den letzten Tagen.
Bis spät abends
stand Jonas in der Küche.
Jetzt muss er die Schlussrechnung
für die Gäste vorbereiten.
Er ist morgens
meist zu nichts zu gebrauchen.
Das ist bei ihm normal.
Er ist ein totaler Morgenmuffel.
Er ist sicher müde.
Die letzten Tage waren anstrengend.
Daher sagte ich ihm,
er solle einen Kaffee trinken.
Vor dem Kaffee
ist er zu gar nichts zu gebrauchen.
Müdigkeit hin oder her - das
Frühstücksbüffet muss fertig werden.
Können wir das
noch etwas rüberschieben?
Den Käse muss man ja abschneiden.
Er muss zuvorderst sein,
damit man schneiden kann.
Das andere ist hier.
- So hat man hier mehr Platz.
Der erste Gast hat schon Hunger.
- Good morning.
Ihren ersten Gästen macht
Familie Rotzler einen Sonderpreis.
Umgerechnet knapp 500 Fr. müssen sie
für das Wochenende bezahlen.
Alles, was wir zusätzlich
eingekauft haben, ist gedeckt.
Das ist wunderbar für uns.
Es ist einfach ein Trainingslager:
Wie muss ein Frühstück aussehen?
Wie läuft das in der Küche?
Wir stellten fest,
dass wir einiges umstellen
und wirklich Ordnung und System
reinbringen müssen.
Jetzt müssen wir über die Bücher
und all das umsetzen.
* Sanfte Musik *
(Jonas)
Bye, guys, bye-bye.
Die vier Jungs aus Stockholm
reisen zufrieden ab.
Familie Rotzler
hat die Feuertaufe bestanden.
(Thomas)
Je näher die Hauptsaison
auf Prince Edward Island kommt,
desto häufiger klingelt
bei Barbara und Thomas das Telefon.
* Telefonklingeln *
Das Telefon, bitte.
Danke.
Barbara Hasenböhler.
Ähm ... Sorry?
Ein Gast
möchte eine ganze Woche buchen.
Doch dafür müsste er während
des Aufenthalts das Zimmer wechseln.
Exactly.
Sehr schön, siehst du?
Wir gratulieren
dem Marketing Departement.
* Barbara lacht. *
Super gemacht.
Wir sind bereits total ausgebucht.
Das ist zwar schön für uns,
aber wenn
nur noch einzelne Tage frei sind,
wird es sehr schwierig,
diese Tage zu füllen.
Jeder gefüllte Tag bedeutet Revenue.
Und auf Revenues -
zu Deutsch "Einnahmen" -
sind Barbara und Thomas
dringend angewiesen.
Coffee.
Seit über zwei Jahren
geben sie Geld aus,
ohne dass gross etwas reinkommt.
Immerhin: Der Umbau
macht sichtbare Fortschritte,
auch wenn noch viele Details fehlen.
Und auch bei Barbara geht es bergauf.
Drei Wochen noch
und sie wird einen Gehgips bekommen.
Das ist das Doppelzimmer Nummer 5.
Das ist das erste Zimmer, das
ab dem 26. Juni vermietet sein wird.
(Frau)
(Barbara)
Ich freue mich darauf,
endlich die Türen zu öffnen
und Gäste zu empfangen.
Der erste Gast
ist etwas Ähnliches wie ...
... ein Schlusspunkt.
Ein Schlusspunkt und gleichzeitig
der Anfang von etwas Neuem.
Wir haben so lange
auf diesen Schlusspunkt gewartet.
* Telefonklingeln *
Geh am besten gleich ran.
Barbara Hasenböhler.
Und so geht es in Kanada weiter:
Wenige Tage vor der Eröffnung
stellen die Handwerker fest,
dass die Gästezimmer
kein warmes Wasser haben.
Come on.
Die fabrikneuen Durchlauferhitzer
müssen ersetzt werden.
Bei den Auswanderern
liegen die Nerven blank.
Warum um alles in der Welt
tun wir uns das eigentlich an?
Ist es das wirklich wert?
Nein.
- Nein?
In Schweden hat Tochter Fiona
ihren ersten Schultag.
Das ist ein grosser Schritt und
auch für mich ein besonderer Moment.
Bleib noch hier drinnen.
Das Verhältnis zu Nachbar Ulf
bekommt erste Risse.
Wir merkten, dass es
nicht ganz so selbstlos ist,
wie es anfangs aussah.
Hallo.
- Salü.
Alain und Anita kommen
in Griechenland ihrem Traum näher.
Sie empfangen erste Gäste.
Wir haben uns sehr auf euch gefreut
und hoffen,
dass wir viele Schildkröten
finden werden.
Sie wollen der Reisegruppe
etwas Besonderes bieten
und führen sie
zu einem versteckten Wasserfall.
Doch von den Reptilien keine Spur.
Nichts.
Hier sonnen sich keine Schildkröten.
Keine.
# U sie stige i Flüger, flüge
mit de Vögu furt, chöme nüm meh hei.
Fantastisch!
# U sie löh hie aues zrugg,
uf de Suechi für nes neus Dahei.
# Sie göh hüt no uf u dervo.
# Uf u dervo, yeah.